hey guys it's Greg here so this is
coming out very late because I finally
did it
I finished season one and two of the
flash a couple of days ago so excited
man that show is one of the coolest
shows ever I wasn't a fan of the flash
prior to watching this show I haven't
read the comics in a day and age when so
many superhero movies are about being
dark or all about like spectacle it's
great to see a superhero story we're
really Tubbs at the heart I cry so much
when I watch that show finally I am
allowing myself to see season 3 of the
flash trailer from Comic Con is coming
out late I'm excited to see how Barry
Allen [ __ ] up the timeline
[Music]
there's only one thing I know about life
I know some things happen by chance
[Music]
oh very things happen because we make
them happen
[Music]
I'm finally free
oh hey slugger hey everything all right
I kitchens great you look really
familiar I've seen you before haven't I
berry
[Music]
some people are just meant to be in your
life
hey who the hell is this this girl is a
richest man in America is there a better
way to get to work than by helicopter
Cisco uh uh don't call me that I don't
know you string me we're not partners
and we're not friends you don't know me
you don't know my life there's something
else to each other where you come from
apparently this isn't your home Barry
it's a mirage it's already screwing with
you and everyone you love and pretty
soon it's gonna take me right down along
with you Oh
what should we call this brave new world
that you've won for us I was thinking
flashpoint
gosh boy as that kid for a while
[Music]
slash
oh god I got chills
Oh my nipples are so hard right now
oh man it kind of gets you a little
angry at Barry for what he did you know
it's understandable because yeah he had
a lot of losses a lot horrible things
happen I invested like 48 episodes into
this show and then to see that like he's
[ __ ] up everything that wasn't even
complete yet you know I didn't get a
have a chance with Iris now just to
start fresh there and I was one of the
only nitpick things I have of the show I
mean put a lot of my friends who are
actual fans the comics iris wes is of
course a big part of the flash and Barry
Allen's life in the show I mean the
whole cat-and-mouse game between super
human vert and the normal girl he's in
love with it's better than a lot of what
I've seen from other shows and movies
but still yeah although whenever it
looks like they're about to get together
or like they kiss or something like that
one moment in season one well forty
time-travels for the first time you
reveal cyrus who he really is
and he kisses her before that I was
cheering alone going run Barry was so
excited and I was really proud that he
got the girl and uh you know it's just
kind of a fortunate that all this shit's
happening although on the flip side I I
did you know there's been a big blur I
mean that has rooted for that for Barry
to go back in the past I actually save
his mom's life is that was such an
unfortunate thing that happened and he
loses his dad and seasons here so his
choice of the matter does make a lot of
sense in terms of character motivation
but dude you like seeing everything so
I'm folding it's just like flashier that
I love that ending with the
reverse-flash yelling at him like who's
the villain now because yeah like very
really altered [ __ ] and he got a did a
bad thing without being a bad guy yeah
I'm excited for Barry too
like I really feel like these are real
people I'm excited for Barry to have you
know connection with his parents and
have that relationship with them like
from the opening shot they showed us
here it seemed like their family's
really good hey slugger
all that I think it'd be a more
interesting approach if like he saved
their lives and then buries that and it
a very like alcoholic abusive dad and
like beat the [ __ ] out of the mom you
know this show is probably gonna do that
it's gonna show us things that are good
things that come from it like yeah he
has his mom and dad back but you know
this is going off the the flashpoint
idea and like I said I haven't read the
comics I barely know [ __ ] about what
flashpoint is I know it's inspired by
the comics of that the alternate reality
or even the flash doesn't even exist at
least in the comics seeing that iris and
him don't know each other I don't know
how much more of that I can really go
through with them playing cat-and-mouse
with each other even though they clearly
both love each other they might as well
just get together at this point come on
already maybe though this is probably
gonna be dr. alchemy I think I said he
pronounced it I don't he's a big villain
of the flash series Andy it's cool that
they're not just making it like hey we
got another speedster who's gonna fight
the flash although I look like Wally
West became Kid Flash thinking the comic
City he's supposed to become Kid Flash
and I know the creators talked about
that like down the road they wanted him
to become that that's pretty cool they
have him in there I hope this show
doesn't become something where it's like
flash is part of a team now like where
he's you know fighting him alongside Kid
Flash and now it's like a speedster team
because then I know dr. wells his
daughter Jesse also got affected by the
particle accelerator even though she's
back on earth to now I'm sure she'll
come back up but I really hope that he
becomes this the main narrative central
focus of the show still and it doesn't
you know try to make it about a bunch of
other heroic speedsters and alchemy I
don't really know much about alchemy and
you know he was a chemist and he became
a criminal flash sent him to prison and
then in prison is where he learned about
the Philosopher's Stone and the
Philosopher's Stone is what allowed him
to become the supervillain that he is
and I would like to do more research on
an alchemy is because one part of me
really likes that I'm not familiar with
the comic origins of this stuff because
all this feels like a very big surprise
to me and a very good and really
refreshing and I don't see anything
coming because I'm not familiar with the
comics Cisco you know this guy's a cool
actor Cisco being like the billionaire
of whoa
Ramon industries I would watch the show
and I would think like Cisco seems like
he would be that brilliant guy who would
one day like have his own major company
like dr. wells I'm not sure how much how
much I would I'll really like this
interpretation of him where he's a
billionaire and easily he's like wealthy
and cocky from it cuz I really like the
like down-to-earth humble relatable
young dude that Cisco is who happens to
be this amazing engineer that's one
thing this show does is it's just show
that challenges here it does it takes
risks and it allows these actors to also
take different for trails of their
characters which is cool I mean all see
a part of me is hoping that this
timeline that we're seeing in season 3
so far that that stays temporary that
somehow Barry goes back and fixes the
mistake he did because I don't know I
like I invested a lot I feel like as an
audience we invested a lot in the first
two seasons and a lot of storylines
didn't even become complete for that
timeline or first four characters that
we wanted to see them go certain places
unless the writers really feel like they
can do better and more with season three
than this specific timeline then okay go
ahead with that but I don't know like I
really love these characters I love
everyone here I would like to see that
timeline still continue and not just
switch it all up completely but I could
be wrong I could be wrong that's one of
the great things about this show is that
it has really challenged in writing and
[ __ ] dig it well thanks for tuning in
if you're new to the channel and you can
subscribe today thank you very much and
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at the Greg L and on Facebook at
the real rejects and shout out to a
subscriber named Denise Vee she comments
a lot she's a really kind human being
she is an Asian girl from her thumbnail
of what I can tell and Asian girls are a
treat that God has given us to look upon
and admire and treat like ladies they
are not objects despite what certain
websites might tell you